[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend seid
etwa dreieinhalb Stunden sitzen sie im
Kanzleramt zusammen und das könnte auch
noch eine lange Nacht werden Streit
Themen gibt es in der Ampelkoalition ja
reichlich und atmosphärisch wie man so
schön sagt ist da auch Luft nach oben
angesichts der Vorwürfe die man sich
zuletzt machte jetzt unmittelbar vor dem
Treffen waren aber alle Beteiligten
sichtlich bemüht nicht noch mehr Öl ins
Feuer zu gießen der Kanzler gab sich
zuversichtlich die Koalition habe sich
Großes vorgenommen und man werde jetzt
einen kleinen Sprung nach vorne machen
das wirft zwar die Frage auf warum dann
nur ein kleiner Sprung aber mehr ist
wohl im Moment nicht drin aus Berlin
Christian
eine solche Ankunft am Kanzleramt
passiert ja nicht einfach sie ist Teil
des Spiels Jeansjacke und Kapuzenpulli
kommen zu Fuß andere lassen sich
Vorfahren alles eingeübt genau wie die
standardflosskeln was erwarten Sie sich
von diesem Treffen guten Kaffee gute
Sitzung was sie drin seit gut drei
Stunden verhandeln versuchen
Klimaschützer draußen nachzustellen eine
FDP die Barrikaden aufbaut gegen alles
was grün ist sieht man da doch das Bild
stimmt nicht sagen die Liberalen
die Grünen haben kein Abo auf eine
politische Agenda in dieser Koalition
sondern wir alle wollen etwas gemeinsam
durchsetzen und werden das auch tun wenn
sie mich jetzt fragen wo sollte es heute
Abend hingehen ein CO2 Limit das ganz
klar regelt wie viel es für CO2 noch
genutzt werden darf aber der Weg dahin
eben über magmechanismen nicht über
Verbote genau das wird heute Abend
hoffentlich verhandelt seit Wochen
streitet die Ampel um die großen Fragen
beim Verkehr und Klimaschutz
planungsbeschleunigung wofür nur für
Schienen und Windkraft wie ist die
Grünen wollen oder weiter auch für neue
Straßen und Autobahnen wie die FDP es
fordert ab fragt Prämien für alte Öl und
Gasheizungen damit alle schneller
umsteigen und wie viel Geld darf die
neue Kindergrundsicherung Kosten um all
das wird gerungen in diesen Stunden im
Kanzleramt ich glaube wir müssen vor
allem jetzt einige große Knoten die auf
dem Tisch liegen durchschlagen was für
mich dabei klar ist jeder von uns drei
wird mal bis an Schatten springen müssen
aber das Ergebnis muss sich natürlich an
der Realität der Klimakrise messen
lassen auch kommunikativ auf Sankt das
Niveau zuletzt durch stechereien
Vertrauensbruch putinvergleiche gar
nicht mehr weit bis zur Gurkentruppe
sagt die Opposition das was die Ampel im
Vorfeld dieses Gipfels angeboten hat das
ist völlig inakzeptabel die Leute werden
verunsichert und diese Ampel hält vor
allen Dingen der Willen zur Macht
zusammen dazu ein Kanzler der oft
unbeteiligt daneben zu stehen scheint
zuletzt wieder öfter zu hören der Ruf
nach dem scholzischen Machtwort da ist
der Kanzler schon in der Verantwortung
weil er der Kanzler ist dass diese
Verlässlichkeit in der Koalition
existiert Olaf Schulz kann jetzt nicht
einfach weiter zuschauen wie grün und
FDP sich zerlegen er muss jetzt als
klimakanzler auftreten er hat ja Klima
Kanzler Plakatieren lassen vor allem
muss es Olaf Scholz gelingen dass jeder
der drei Partner etwas gewinnt an diesem
Abend wir bieten gerne immer Kompromisse
an wir versuchen zu vermitteln und ganz
oft klappt das ja auch und manchmal
klappt halt eher später und vielleicht
klappt erst heute Abend im Koalition
aber wir kommen zu Ergebnis und er wird
dabei wieder darauf hinweisen dass das
Geld nicht vom Himmel fällt kein Wunder
dass das alles dauert
und darüber wollen wir mit einem
prominenten Grünen sprechen mit Toni
Hofreiter guten Abend nach Berlin Herr
Hofreiter guten Abend wir haben es
gerade eben in den Beitrag gehört und
fordert sogar schon die Union die
Opposition den Kanzler dazu auf sich
doch daran zu erinnern dass er
klimakanzler sein will wie finden sie
das
ich finde es traurigerweise ist ja
nachvollziehbar allerdings sollte die
Union sich natürlich auch überlegen
welchen Beitrag sie geleistet hat in der
Vergangenheit aber natürlich hat man die
Erwartung dass der Kanzler sich darum
bemüht dass das was im Koalitionsvertrag
steht auch umgesetzt wird nämlich die
ganzen Streitereien die in ihrem
Vorbericht dargestellt worden sind die
sind eigentlich alle im
Koalitionsvertrag bereits besprochen
worden und entsprechend geregelt worden
es gibt bloß zu viele die sich nicht
mehr daran erinnern dass es im Kern im
Koalitionsvertrag geregelt ist
Koalitionsvertrag war dann vielleicht
nicht detailfreudig genug gewesen so
dass man sich missverstehen kann und gab
es diese Woche ja einen richtigen
Wutausbruch von Robert Habeck bei den
Grünen wenn er bei ihrer Sitzung in in
Weimar wo er sagte wir haben wirklich
keinen Bock mehr darauf dass in einer
fortschrittskoalition nur eine für
Fortschritt verantwortlich ist und die
anderen für die Verhinderung von
Fortschritt das wird ganz schön
dünnhäutig ärgert ist sie so sehr dass
es der FDP gelingt die Grünen als
verbotspartei darzustellen
darum geht es denn es geht darum dass
alle Seiten
letztendlich sich an das halten was
besprochen worden ist und wenn es darum
geht die Heizungen zu modernisieren also
ist es vieles im Koalitionsvertrag
bereits geregelt worden und letztes Jahr
entsprechend bereits alles im
Koalitionsausschuss besprochen worden
und deswegen ist es natürlich schon
absurd wenn man sich jetzt in etwas
anderen Zeiten wo vielleicht der Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine und die
Mangel Lage beim Gas die damals
befürchtet worden ist nicht mehr so
präsent ist dass man sich dann plötzlich
nicht mehr daran erinnern kann das macht
natürlich das Arbeiten schon sehr
schwierig die Frage ist wo dann da das
Hauptproblem legt sie haben gesagt also
das Hauptproblem ist eigentlich nicht
die FDP sondern das Kanzleramt ja der
Meinung bin ich auch das ist das
Hauptproblem nicht am Ende kann der
Kanzler nicht unbeteiligt daneben stehen
und wie zum Beispiel bei der Regelung
auf europäischer Ebene die flotten
Grenzwerte in Richtung Null abzusenken
was im Kern auch alles geregelt war dann
sogar noch so zu tun als wenn er auf der
einen Seite nichts damit zu tun hätte
und auf der anderen Seite diejenigen die
uns Schwierigkeiten auf europäischer
Ebene machen auch noch zu ermutigen also
damit man jetzt die FDP diejenigen die
uns Schwierigkeiten machen aber er war
Herr Hofreiter das ein Kanzler in der
Koalition im er moderierend um einen
wirkt das ist ja jetzt kein neues
Phänomen also Frau Merkel hätte sonst
die SPD und die CSU und ihrer Koalition
auch nicht zusammenhalten können kann er
nicht ständig mit der Faust auf den
Tisch schlagen und wird dann auch nicht
ständig im Sinne der Grünen entscheiden
nein natürlich nicht aber er sollte halt
moderieren und zu moderieren gehört halt
dazu dass man auf europäische Ebene
nicht den ganzen
Entscheidungsmechanismen in aller größte
Schwierigkeiten bringt
Sache ist ja jetzt vom Tisch darüber
wird heute Abend auch nicht mehr
gestritten oder
die eful Sache ist heute Abend
vielleicht vom Tisch aber die
Auswirkungen auf europäischer Ebene
dieser äußerst schlechten Moderation die
sind überhaupt nicht vom Tisch das wird
unser auf europäischer Ebene noch
einiges kosten war nämlich so Länder wie
Ungarn plötzlich sagen ja wenn
Deutschland ganz am Ende wo eigentlich
alles bereits besprochen ist doch noch
mal Dinge aufmachen kann dann können wir
das auch und so kann man auf europäische
Ebene nicht agieren deswegen das was Sie
gesagt haben dass er moderieren soll das
ist ja genau das was ich erwartete und
insbesondere auf europäische Ebene
erwartet und genau das ist in der
vergangenen Wochen und Monaten nicht
ausreichend passiert das natürlich auch
der Vorsitzende des europaausschusses im
Bundestag das ist auch auch ihr
Steckenpferd Thema und sagt der Kanzler
wir müssen bei allem was wir machen
aufpassen dass wir die Leute auch
mitnehmen das war niemanden überfordern
und dann hat heute abend gesehen in
Berlin der Volksentscheid über den
Klimaneutralität bis 2030 war nicht
erfolgreich und man sieht auch ein
Umfragen Verbrenner aus das macht der
Mehrheit der Gesellschaft eher Angst
also es ist auch schwierig diese Themen
dann einfach so durchzusetzen wie das
vielleicht die Grünen und auch die
Grünen Wähler wollen naja das beim
Verbrenner aus wenn sie da wieder auf
die europäische Ebene gehen dann sagen
einem die Leute man ist ja gewohnt dass
in Deutschland quatscht Debatten geführt
werden eine echte europäische Regelung
ist nicht dass der Verbrenner verbotene
sie finden es war Verbrenner sogar gar
nicht da gibt's eine ganz ganz schlank
hier oben
das stimmt noch nicht ganz schlanke
kluge Regelung Autos dürfen ab 2035 kein
CO2 mehr ausstoßen wie sie das machen
das entscheiden ganz allein die
Autofirmen sie können da z.B ein
Wasserstoff Verbrenner machen sie können
Batterie elektrisches Auto machen sie
können Wasserstoff elektrisches Auto
machen das kommt nämlich noch dazu dass
wir hier halt absurde Debatten häufig
führen weil viele sozusagen über etwas
debattieren was überhaupt nicht in den
Regelungen steht ja auch über den Ausbau
von Autobahn geredet
ob man da nicht doch ein paar Kilometer
vielleicht doch dann auch noch
zusätzlich aus weil ich meine wenn die
Leute mit E-Wagen darüber fahren dann
müssen die Grünen über diesen Schatten
doch eigentlich springen können
wir haben wieder das Geld noch die
Kapazitäten noch das Personal auch das
ist in den Koalitionsverhandlungen
ausführlich und detailliert besprochen
waren und dann haben wir gesagt ja wir
haben ein riesen Problem an den
Autobahnen und es ist das ernährungsstau
das ist das Problem dass die Brücken uns
zusammenfallen und darauf müssen wir den
Fokus legen da waren sich im Kern alle
einig und es ist halt ein Problem wenn
das eineinhalb Jahre später wo sich auch
überhaupt nichts geändert hat außer das
bewusst geworden ist dass die Brücken
sogar noch schlechteren Zustand sind es
ist erst der paar Tage her dass die
Brücke von der 45 die Zentrale ist
gesprengt werden er musste und neu
gebaut werden muss also wenn sich
eineinhalb Jahre später wo sich die
Probleme eher verschärft haben was ich
nicht mal daran erinnert was im
Koalitionsvertrag gesprochen worden ist
dann ist es halt ein Problem
das merkt man nein ich bin gar nicht
sauer ich bin ehrlich gesagt darüber
verärgert gar nicht über die sachliche
Frage sondern dass das
was abgesprochen worden ist nicht gilt
und das macht die Politik so schwierig
wenn man immer wieder aufs Neue
verhandeln muss man hat zum
Koalitionsvertrag besprochen dann hat
man es in koalitionsausschüssen
festgelegt und dann muss es aufs neue
wieder verhandelt werden man kann nicht
Dinge drei vier Mal immer wieder neu
verhandeln nämlich dann kommt man nicht
voran und damit zerstört man halt auch
vertrauen
wie das heute Abend gelaufen ist Herr
Hofreiter danke für das Gespräch ich
danke Ihnen
immer Wechsel gestern Abend hatte Putin
ja angekündigt Atomwaffen im Nachbarland
Belarus zu stationieren darauf gab es
heute internationale Reaktionen und
damit beginnen jetzt bei dir die
Nachrichten eins ja bei der NATO und der
Bundesregierung ist die Ankündigung mit
Kritik aufgenommen worden im Auswärtigen
Amt nannte man Putins Vorgehen einen
weiteren Versuch der nuklearen
Einschüchterung die NATO sprach von
einer gefährlichen und
unverantwortlichen Rhetorik die Ukraine
forderte eine Dringlichkeitssitzung des
UN-Sicherheitsrates
die Stadt Frankfurt am Main wird
weiterhin von einem Sozialdemokraten
regiert in der Stichwahl um das Amt des
Oberbürgermeisters setzte sich
SPD-Kandidat Mike Joseph überraschend
gegen Uwe Becker von der CDU durch im
ersten Wahlgang vor drei Wochen lag
Josef noch über 10% Punkte hinter Bäcker
die Wahl wurde nötig weil im November
letzten Jahres der damalige
spd-amtsinhaber Peter Feldmann abgewählt
worden war
in Berlin es war eben schon angesprochen
ist ein Volksentscheid geschaltet der
zum Ziel hatte dass sich die Hauptstadt
verpflichtet schon bis 2030 klimaneutral
zu werden und nicht wie bislang
vorgesehen bis 2045 gut 600.000 Stimmen
für dieses Ziel wäre nötig gewesen aber
von den rund 2,4 Millionen
Wahlberechtigten gab es nur rund 440.000
ja stimmen und rund 420.000 Nein stimmen
die Wahlbeteiligung lag bei gut 30%
bei bootsunglücken im Mittelmeer sind
erneut zahlreiche Migranten ums Leben
gekommen die tunesische Küstenwache
erklärte mindestens 29 Menschen aus
Ländern südlich der Sahara seien vor der
Küste ertrunken im Hafen der
italienischen Insel Lampedusa hat das
Hilfsschiff Louis Michelle 180 gerettete
Menschen an Land gebracht teilte die
dortige Küstenwache mit das Schiff wurde
vorübergehend von den Behörden
festgesetzt weil die Helfer bei ihrer
Rettungsaktion gegen Vorschriften
verstoßen hätten
israels Ministerpräsident Netanjahu hat
Verteidigungsminister galant entlassen
gelernt der wienetan Yahoo der
lekhutpartei angehört hatte überraschend
die eigene Regierung zum Stopp der
umstrittenen Justizreform und zum Dialog
mit Kritikern aufgerufen gegen die
Reform gibt es seit Monaten Proteste
kritiker sehen die Gewaltenteilung in
Gefahr
nach den verheerenden Tornados im Süden
der USA ist die Zahl der Todesopfer auf
mindestens 26 gestiegen im Bundesstaat
Mississippi wurden ganze Stadtteile dem
Erdboden gleich gemacht die US-Regierung
rief für die betroffenen Regionen den
Katastrophenfall aus damit werden
Bundesmittel für erste Nothilfemaßnahmen
und für den Wiederaufbau freigegeben
ein so umfangreichen Warnstreik wie
Morgen hat es hierzulande noch nicht
gegeben im Verkehrssektor wird im Grunde
genommen nichts mehr gehen Bahnhöfe
Flughäfen Schifffahrt überall wird
gestreikt in sieben Bundesländern auch
in Nahverkehr Fortkommen wird man dort
nur mit Auto oder Fahrrad die Staus kann
man sich jetzt schon ausmalen der kann
bleibt wohl besser zu Hause Alexander
Pool beginnt seinen Bericht in München
da ging es mit den Warnstreiks heute
schon los
hier geht schon heute gar nichts mehr
keine Staats- und Landungen am Flughafen
München wo um diese Zeit an normalen
Tagen tausende Passagiere abgefertigt
werden herrscht heute gähnende Leere für
manche kommt die streiknachricht völlig
überraschend
ich muss zurück nach Sizilien da wohne
ich jetzt sitze ich hier fest
traurig sowas an vielen deutschen
Flughäfen beginnt der Streik am Montag
laut Flughafenverband können rund
380.000 Geschäfts-
wir werden eigentlich von Frankfurt
geflogen Morgen und so jetzt fliegen wir
heute von Hamburg also wir haben Glück
gehabt dass unser Flug heute ist und ich
morgen da sind wir auch ziemlich dankbar
weil wir es morgen gewesen wäre es
natürlich ein Problem für uns gewesen
ungewöhnlich viel Betrieb heute auch auf
dem Hauptbahnhof in München zum morgigen
Streik hat die Eisenbahn und
Verkehrsgewerkschaft EVG rund 230.000
Beschäftigte aufgerufen nicht nur die
Fernzüge stehen still auch die meisten
regional- und S-Bahnen fallen aus viele
hier mussten ihre Pläne über den Haufen
werfen eigentlich geflogen
wir werden eigentlich von Hamburg nach
München geflogen und so sind wir jetzt
von Flensburg mit dem Zug nach Hamburg
und dann
im Zug gefahren
eine scheinbar einfache Lösung doch
Arbeitsrechtler Hans Pfitzner gibt zu
Bedenken nicht jeder kann die in
Anspruch nehmen
das bemüht sich nach dem Arbeitgeber
oder nach einer entsprechenden
Betriebsvereinbarung habe ich eine gute
Betriebsvereinbarung habe ich unter
Umständen ein Rechtsanspruch drauf
gesetzlich gibt es keinen Rechtsanspruch
zu Hause bleiben zu dürfen grundsätzlich
gilt das Risiko rechtzeitig oder
überhaupt zur Arbeit zu kommen liegt
ganz allein beim Arbeitnehmer
das heißt wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
meine Kinder nicht mehr zur Kita bringen
kann und deswegen nicht zur Arbeit
erscheinen kann dann ist es zwar keine
Pflichtverletzung weil ich kann nichts
dafür gleichwohl kann man da Arbeitgeber
dann für diese Zeit den Lohn kürzen und
so wird der so alt tägliche Weg zum Büro
morgen für viele eine echte
Herausforderung
Arbeitsmarktexperten rechnen damit dass
es hierzulande künftig häufiger
Arbeitskämpfe und Streiks geben könnte
angesichts der vielen offenen Stellen
bewege sich der Arbeitsmarkt in Richtung
eines arbeitnehmermarktes quer durch
alle Branchen werden ja Fachkräfte und
Auszubildende gesucht das dürfte sich
noch verschärfen wenn die
geburtenstarken Jahrgänge in Rente gehen
könnte man vermuten das künftig eher
mehr und länger gearbeitet werden muss
wenn weniger Köpfe das gleiche stemmen
müssen doch es könnte auch ganz anders
kommen in Großbritannien gab es jetzt
dann interessantes Experiment mit der
vier Tage Woche bei vollem Lohn auch in
Deutschland gibt es Firmen die dieses
Modell inzwischen anbieten wenn dazu von
Christian Kirsch und malte
die einen bleiben Montags zu Hause die
anderen freitags diese Dresdner
Steuerkanzlei hat die Vier-Tage-Woche
eingeführt bei vollem Lohn
das Ziel ist dass die Mitarbeiter die
geplanten Aufträge schaffen und wann sie
das machen ist es nicht völlig egal sie
haben 34 Stunden Woche Zeit dafür und
dann machen sie das normalerweise von
Montag bis Donnerstag ein Problem der
Kanzlei es waren kaum noch Bewerbungen
eingegangen inzwischen mangelt es selbst
in Steuerkanzleien an Fachkräften
Beschäftigte gehen in den Ruhestand der
Nachwuchs bleibt aus
die Arbeitswelt im rasanten Wandel
Homeoffice künstliche Intelligenz all
das ist längst Realität
Roboter übernehmen Arbeit wird schneller
effektiver und trotzdem arbeiten wir
genauso viel wie zuvor warum das fragt
sich auch Philipp frei er ist
arbeitsforscher am Karlsruher Institut
für Technologie für ihn ist die vier
Tage Woche eine konsequente Antwort wenn
man eh unter Fachkräftemangel leidet
dann ist ja eigentlich die erste
Reaktion erstmal wirklich viel Zeit aus
den Leuten rauszuholen und jetzt nicht
noch die Arbeitszeit zu verkürzen aber
tatsächlich gibt es auch
Handwerksbetriebe die eine vier Tage
Woche eingeführt haben und die davor
große Probleme hatten Azubis zum
Beispiel zu finden und jetzt deutlich
mehr gute Azubi Bewerbung bekommen als
sie Ausbildungsplätze haben man kann man
sieht also eine 4 Tage kann auch zu
Bekämpfung vom Fachkräftemangel
beitragen weniger Arbeit als Chance
forschende haben eine Studie mit
britischen Unternehmen durchgeführt die
Ergebnisse verblüffen nach sechs Monaten
fällt Versuch mit 2900 Beschäftigten
wollen 56 von 61 Unternehmen die vier
Tage Woche beibehalten obwohl sie
dieselben löhnezahlen wie zuvor
erstaunlich ist dass die Mitarbeiter
zufriedener und gesünder sind die
Kündigungen sanken um
57%, die Zahl der Krankmeldungen um
ganze 65 Prozent zugleich gab es für die
Unternehmen sogar ein Umsatzplus obwohl
die Mitarbeiter wöchentlich einen ganzen
Tag weniger arbeiteten historisch kann
man ja beobachten dass die Arbeitszeiten
immer gefallen sind seit der
industriellen Revolution und erst ab
1990 haben das mit dem Trend zu tun dass
die vollzeitwoche stagniert hat bei um
die 38 Stunden und vor dem Hintergrund
könnte man glaube ich sagen dass eine
vier Tage Woche eher eine Rückkehr zu
einem fortschrittsversprechen ist dass
über Jahrhundert hinweg getragen hat ein
fortschrittsversprechen dass wirklich
nur Vorteile hat kritiker bemängeln das
wertvolle Pausen wegfallen könnten und
alles nur schneller erledigt werden muss
man kann nicht alles haben man kann
nicht sowohl alles beibehalten so wie es
war und dann einfach sagen wir arbeiten
vier Tage also klar muss man vielleicht
auf eine auf keine Ahnung zwei von fünf
Gesprächen dann verzichten auf dem Gang
aber dafür hat man immer noch drei
Gespräche und dann den ganzen freien Tag
um das arbeiten effektiver zu machen hat
die Kanzlei viele Abläufe digitalisiert
und sogenannte fokuszeiten eingeführt
Anrufe und Mails kommen nur zu
bestimmten Zeiten an das Arbeiten wird
konzentrierter und die vier Tage Woche
macht zufrieden also Freunde die nicht
das erzähle bzw auch meine Eltern die
können sich das gar nicht vorstellen
dass das funktioniert man hat diesen
freien Tag bekommen und nutzt den dann
auch effizient und effektiv also für
Familie für Haushalt für noch mehr Sport
und ich möchte nicht sondern 5 Tage
Woche zurück wenn ich ganz ehrlich nicht
nur hier könnte es in Zukunft also
heißen dass weniger Arbeit am Ende für
alle mehr bedeutet
und jetzt geht es bei dir noch mal
weiter mit dem Sport an diesem
Wochenende und zwar mit dem Wintersport
beim Skispringen im finnischen lachti
kam Karl Geiger heute auf Platz 3 hinter
dem japaneri Jojo Kobayashi und Stefan
Kraft aus Österreich
ebenfalls Platz drei erreicht der
Katharina Hennig in lacht die zum
langlaufsaisonfinale Hennig holte beim
Massenstart über 20 km im klassischen
Stil den 8 Podestplatz ihrer Karriere
gewonnen hat heute Anakin calva aus
Norwegen vor Jonas und Link aus Schweden
Erik Frenzel hat viele Jahre lang die
Nordische Kombination dominiert und
geprägt in lacht die bestritt der heute
sein letztes Weltcup Rennen der 40 Platz
wurde da zur Nebensache beim Einlauf ins
Ziel standen Frenzels Kollegen Spalier
für den König der Kombinierer und
feierten seine Erfolge mit seiner Sekt
Dusche dreimal Olympia Gold sieben WM
Titel 43 Weltcupsiege und 5 mal der
Gesamtweltcupsieg mit dieser Bilanz
verabschiedet sich der 34-Jährige in den
sportlichen Ruhestand
angefangen hat es in den Baracken einer
ehemaligen Ziegelei im hessischen
Eschborn aus einem provisorischen
Fernsehstudio ging hier am ersten April
vor 60 Jahren das ZDF auf Sendung eine
kurze Begrüßung und dann gab es auch
gleich die erste heute
Nachrichtensendung die sich unter
anderem mit den eierpreisen beschäftigte
war ja schließlich kurz vor Ostern
internationale Themen gab es aber auch
etwa die Weltausstellung in New York
get Anhalt hat tief ins Archiv gegriffen
und erinnert an 60 Nachrichten Jahre im
ZDF
als sie 1963 das Fernsehen neu erfanden
da wussten die Pioniere vom ZDF das
zweierlei wichtig war jeden Tag eine
gute Nachrichtensendung und jedes Jahr
einen guten Jahresrückblick
es begann wie sich manche erinnern
werden mit seriösen Herren die Tiefe
zeitkritische Gedanken äußerten und
einander eine immer unübersichtlichere
Welt erklärten in der grausame Kriege
geführt wurden wie von den Amerikanern
in Vietnam oder ihren Prag die Russen
Panzer gegen friedliche Demonstranten
schickten
jeder drohte jedem mit Atomraketen dann
kamen die Beatles die einen eroberten
den Mond und die anderen eroberten die
Herzen und so sahen die oft zitierten
alt 68er aus als sie noch jung waren
die 70er mit ihren modischen
Entgleisungen brachten auch eine neue
Lässigkeit ins ZDF-Studio wo nun der
Leitwolf des Chronisten Rudels das
Kommando führte Karl-heinz Rudolf
auf viel Erbauliches konnte er erstmal
nicht zurückblicken es gab vor allem
immer wieder Terror in München und im
Nahen Osten und dann wieder bei uns Mord
Geiselnahme und Flugzeug Entführung der
deutsche Herbst lehrte alle das Frösteln
und die Energiekrise lehrte die
Autobahnen
in den 80ern entdeckten viele ihre tiefe
Abneigung gegen alles atomare und zwar
schon vor Tschernobyl die Fans des ZDF
Jahresrückblicks entdeckten diese
niedlichen Kalenderblätter und die
Supermächte entdeckten dass man doch
miteinander reden konnte was zum
Mauerfall führte und zu einem großen
Freudentaumel
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es hätte so schön werden können in den
90ern Einheit Fußball-Weltmeister
heiße Tänze statt Kalter Krieg aber da
explodierte der Balkan dann verunglückte
Prinzessin Diana beim Fußball klappte
auch nichts mehr einziger Lichtblick die
großen Dichter und Denker von heute und
dem heute journal die nun den
Jahresrückblick kommentierten
und uns durch die großen Krisen des
neuen Jahrtausends Lotsen
finanzflüchtlings Euro und Klimakrise
Natur und nuklear Katastrophen immer
wieder Terror und dann die Pandemie und
wieder Krieg
und man könnte fast verzweifeln
wenn es nicht auch immer wieder so viel
Schönes und der haben es und erhebendes
und tröstliches gäbe auf der Zeitreise
durch 60 Jahre ZDF
[Musik]
60 Nachrichten Jahre ZDF 60 Jahre
Weltgeschichte online auf zdf.de finden
Sie dazu ein großes Album mit dem Titel
Zeitreise Bilder aus 60 Jahren zu jedem
Jahr gibt es eine Doku zum Beispiel für
1970 mit dem historischen Kniefall Willy
Brandts in Warschau
was der Jahresrückblick für 2023 alles
enthalten wird wissen wir jetzt noch
nicht aber auf die nächste Woche können
wir schon mal schauen da sind ja einige
Ereignisse schon geplant der Ausblick
von Jörg
[Musik]
bundesweit wird sich morgen so gut wie
nichts bewegen keine Bahnen oder Busse
auch beim Flugverkehr muss mit massiven
Beeinträchtigungen gerechnet werden mit
dem Mega Streiktag will Verdi den Druck
erhöhen morgen beginnt die dritte
Verhandlungsrunde im Tarifstreit des
öffentlichen Dienstes
militärische Würdigung für Christine
Lambrecht am Dienstag wird die
ex-verteidigungsministerin mit einem
großen Zapfenstreich offiziell
verabschiedet mit Januar hatte Lambrecht
nach anhaltender Kritik an ihre
Amtsführung um ihre Entlassung gebeten
die sichere und bezahlbare
Energieversorgung wird ab Mittwoch im
Fokus stehen wenn sich die
Energieminister der Länder treffen den
Vorsitz hat Sachsen-Anhalt zwei Tage
will man unter anderem über eine
Absenkung der Stromsteuer sowie den
beschleunigten Ausbau der
Wasserstoffwirtschaft beraten
der britische König Charles der dritte
und seine Ehefrau Camilla kommen am
Mittwoch nach Deutschland der Royale
Staatsbesuch soll drei Tage dauern unter
anderem wird Charles im Deutschen
Bundestag eine Rede halten
bleiben noch die Wetteraussichten die
noch nicht so richtig zur seit heute
wieder geltenden Sommerzeit passen
morgen gibt es bei einem Mix aus vielen
Wolken und etwas Sonne immer wieder
Schnee Regen und Graupelschauer Gewitter
sind auch dabei an den Alpen kann es
länger schneiden bei einem lebhaften
Nordwestwind werden ein bis acht Grad
erreicht die weiteren Aussichten am
Dienstag gibt es nur noch wenige Schauer
im Südosten am Mittwoch steigen die
Temperaturen wieder bis 17 Grad und am
Donnerstag gibt es regen für alle
das war es von uns an diesem Sonntag mit
Krimi geht es gleich weiter dr
Liebermann und Inspektor Reinhard
ermitteln in Wien des frühen 20
Jahrhunderts
dann die nächste heute Express und uns
morgen wieder auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]